Bob let's say I'm a beginning
screenwriter where would I began to
research film history so I could broaden
my perspective of storytelling I think
wonderful place to begin as at the
beginning and look at the entire history
of movies because the situation at the
beginning was kind of like we are right
now when movies began nobody knew with
his business whatever turn into and no
one really knew how to tell a story and
so they wind it and you had the Lumiere
brothers sending guys out onto the
street with tripods and cameras and
making 47 movies and at Georgia madea's
you know concocting little fantasies in
the studio and in their own primitive
way they were attempting to figure out
how to tell stories in film and so I
personally think that's the greatest
place to be in at all it's simple it's
easy and it's clear because the
challenge is in making movies are always
the same no matter what kind of material
what kind of equipment you're using you
always want to attempt to find some kind
of sympathetic character and it's going
to be a struggle and there's going to be
the three acts and that stuff doesn't
ever go away and I think I find that
when you begin to look at some of the
movies from the past you begin to get
some perspective on who you are and if
in a story you want to tell and what it
owes to some of the world in the past I
guess whats Alan Watts that the Zen
philosopher has said something about the
ocean and the fish and everybody knows
it but I'll repeat it anyway which is I
don't know who it was who discovered the
ocean but it certainly wasn't the fish
and we are fish in our own little ocean
here and I think it helps to get out of
that little contemporary ocean a little
bit and to look at other possibilities
other times when filmmakers we're
attempting to tell
stories in movies or make documentaries
and movies because then it gives your
level of freedom but you don't have
otherwise once you're outside of it once
you can step out of side your little
moment in time and your world you then
have a kind of choice you can say I love
it it's fantastic I want to get right
back into it or else you can say I'm out
of there I see it a different way and I
want to tell stories differently I want
to be different kind of filmmaker want
to be a different kind of person so my
answer is start at the beginning and
work your way through that's really what
my book is all about
you